le dont un spectaculaire à l'image de
piquer subban 10 millions de dollars à
l'hôpital de montréal pour enfants
succès tant l'engagement philanthropique
le plus important pris par une athlète
professionnel au canada l'été dernier le
ch et la ville de montréal ont pris un
engagement lentement vers moi
alors aujourd'hui c'est mon tour de
prendre un engagement vrai que piquet
souvent a signé un contrat de 72
millions l'an dernier avec le canadien
il veut simplement redonner dans ma vie
je pense que c'est ce ne sont pas nous
accomplissement qui nous définissent des
tennis mais bien nos actions envers les
autres l'atrium de l'hôpital porte déjà
son nom son argent ira à la formation la
recherche et aussi pour les familles
fragilisées financièrement comme l'a été
celle de tristan atteint du spina bifida
tout ce travail sera mené directement le
talent c'est compliqué à gérer tout ça
et je pense les fait défaut d'avoir
financièrement sa part levé 1
nuages au dessus de la famille que je
suis fier de marché dans la pâte de mon
idole jean béliveau des mots qui ont
donné des frissons à la veuve de jean
béliveau piqué le francophile piqué le
philanthrope il devient soudainement un
excellent candidat au poste de capitaine
même si max pacioretty a une longueur
d'avancé
depuis le début je dis toujours que je
voulais avoir max max m'a fait penser
beaucoup agi de la façon qui agit de
façon par laquelle passe que lui et
plein de vie mais ça serait pas très bon
capitaine pareil au canada
mais pour le jeune tristan ce qui rêve
d'aller aux paralympiques piqué subban
vont bien plus que ces 10 millions une
inspiration une nouvelle idole qui fut
proche du mot faut préférer une hausse
expliquée change et d'idoles way i see
diane s'ouvrir à tous canada à montréal